ALINE PEZENTE: So, my
name is Aline Pezente.
I was a Sloan Fellows
'18 graduate student.
I was working with Anjali
at an independent study
for farmer's economy and
the usage of technology.
So, there is an ever increasing
need to invest in agriculture.
And one of the biggest
challenge for that
is the credit, access for
affordable loans for farmers.
And we have been
discussing with Anjali
about how we can use
technology to solve this issue.
And what is the design
of this technology
that we can use for
farmers that they can
have better access to credit?
But not only that, how we can
help the lenders to access
those farmers, which
are mostly remote areas,
and they lack data.
So we have been
working with Anjali
on thinking on as
in these problems,
and also restructuring
the right questions
that we should think about
to find the proper solutions.
We thought it was more
design thinking, and design
of thinking about the process,
and how is the clients,
and how are--
not the clients, but the
farmers' and the lenders'
perspective, with their lenses,
what are the main questions
that they do while they
are in the credit process?
And what are the
status quo today--
what are the failures
of these status quo?
And where we find
the technologies
that have a compelling user
case to deliver solutions
for lack of data and connection
between farmers and lenders.
So it was a very systematic
approach that we been opting
and how we think of all those
technologies and innovation,
and deployed this
to this problem.
So, I manage my time with
weekly meetings with Anjali
for a period of time.
We set up very
narrow deliverables.
And between the process,
we were iterating
with some of the professors
and some of the resources
that I needed.
And I took the discipline to
having that in my schedule
so we could deliver and
have fruitful discussions
every meeting that
we had together.
And what I learned,
though, in this process
with her was how to--
we systematically
think or how we make--
we make the right questions.
And from the right
questions, we start
to find the solutions which
derives to the right questions.
And where do we
find the resources?
And it's a system
dynamic way of doing--
of formulating your
problem statement,
which was very helpful
for me in this process
of working in the project.
Anjali was super relevant
to help us to think, OK,
to solve this for
this challenge,
we need an expert
in different areas.
Who are the experts?
And she connected us with those
experts that eventually came
up and help us to contribute.
And also, she connected us
with many interpreters and also
companies outside
the scope of MIT.
For example, she connected
us with a guy from India
from one of--
the largest solar
panel companies
who also in certain sense
is still in contact with us
on thinking about contribution,
with Tata Center who also will
contribute with our research.
I think that that's
the environment
that MIT brings to you.
It's quite unique,
right, this possibility
that help us to
connect with people
from different backgrounds.
Not only that, they
are the experts
in the background in the world.
They are the most renowned
faculty members, scientists.
They will add you a
different perspective.
There is this ocean of
think of different ideas,
different perspective that
helps you to build up your own.
This is something
that is unique at MIT.
Also the capacity
of the connection,
right, because the
world expands to you
and it opens because
you're at MIT.
So there is nothing equal like
that at all in any other place.
All the feedbacks
that I was iterating
through the connections
that we establish
through the process in this
course were quite valuable.
Actually, every
feedback, every iteration
shaped somehow the process
of what we are doing now.
And that's the valuable
thing of this course
is also to have the possibility
to hear other opinions.
Not only-- if you
stay on your own path,
you're blind to what
is new or outside.
And that prevents you
somehow to make innovation,
which is not the case here.
You see so many different
things sometimes that you never
thought before.
And that changes.
And that improves
what you are doing.
I guess the biggest
challenge in this process
is still having the
discipline to find a proper--
to having the discipline
in this structure
to find a solution because
there are so many elements
because you learn how to think.
And seeing the whole
world and to try
to grasp the answers in a
systematic and organized way
was, for me, a challenge
in the beginning.
But I learned how to navigate
that eventually later.
So it's now-- it's an
interesting process
that you learned how to
deal with so many variables
in making the puzzles to
deliver to a whole-- a clear and
transparent picture.
Well, this project one, there
is two branches of that.
One is a startup that I'm
doing, which we already
are creating the fintech,
which is exclusively
dedicated to the
agricultural market, which
is the first in the market
where we use data analytics.
And we designed the
process in this course
to improve and deliver
better financial solutions
to both lenders and
farmers so we allow
them to have affordable loans.
And on top of that,
there is also--
because this is so unique
and so new in the world,
we are doing
research with Anjali
and other professors, senior
faculty members at MIT
with support from
the data center
as well to study the economic
behavior of farmers and lenders
with more data.
This data will help to solve
for the problems of sustainable
financing.
Or in economy-- in
conclusion, we don't know.
So that's one of
the investigations
that we are doing.
That's one of the
next challenge,
and again, some of the
answers that we are trying
to find for this question.